[Music]
straight ahead on long crime daily a
former louisville police officer will
soon stand trial in connection to the
death of brianna taylor law and crime
network is in kentucky with the latest
plus a monumental victory for female
soccer players what stipulations went
into the 24 million dollar equal pay
settlement and opening statements
presented as a one-time ohio doctor
stands trial for murder ultimately our
case is about the fact that william
husel caused the death of our 14 victims
there's no such thing as a medical
murder case
and that this is not a murder case but
first a verdict is reached the death of
a mod arbory federal trial
no one should fear that if they go out
for a run
they will be targeted and killed because
of the color of their skin long crime
daily covering court cases from coast to
coast
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm brian buckmeyer along with terry
austin nearly two years after the death
of a mod arbory a verdict is reached in
the federal hate crime trial stemming
from his death all three defendants were
found guilty on all federal accounts
just months after guilty verdicts were
handed down in a separate state trial
the unanimous verdict for trousing
michael gregory mcmichael and william
roddy bryan was reached after just four
hours of deliberation the defendants
were charged with interference with
rights a hate crime and attempted
kidnapping prosecutors say aubrey a 25
year old black man was going for a jog
near his brunswick georgia home on
february 23 2020. that's when the
mcmichaels began tailing him in a pickup
truck later claiming they believe aubry
was responsible for a string of
robberies in their neighborhood traffic
michael eventually shot and killed aubry
brian captured the incident on his cell
phone a federal judge ruled a sentencing
hearing will be scheduled after
pre-sentencing reports are filed all
three men already face life in prison
stemming from the separate georgia state
trial brian is eligible for parole after
30 years the mcmichaels will serve 20
years on top of their life sentences
following federal verdict u.s attorney
general commended the jury's decision in
a press conference
although we welcome the jury's verdict
the only acceptable outcome in this
matter
would have been mr arbory returning
safely to his loved ones
two years ago
his family and his friends should be
preparing to celebrate his 28th birthday
later this spring not mourning the
second anniversary of his death
tomorrow
ahmad arbory should be alive today
joining us today is criminal defense
attorney bernard violina and terry
austin bernardo was this the verdict you
expected for these three men how long do
you think they will serve time in jail
when the sentencing is handed down
absolutely i definitely expected a
guilty verdict on these hate crime
federal hate crime charges today was a
win for racial justice given the
voluminous evidence that was presented
by the prosecution of hate text messages
hate messages phone calls as well as
from conversation from prior colleagues
i expected this to be the verdict and
glad that the jury got it right in terms
of sentencing of course since travis
mcmichael as well as uh travis mcmichael
as well as his father they're both
already serving life sentences without
the possibility of parole so we know
that they will never see the light of
what day in regards to william roddy
brian though remember he's eligible for
parole at 30 years so it is possible
that he can get either a concurrent
sentence or a sentence that would still
allow him to see the light of day
outside of jail yeah and i expect them
both to try to get their sentences
probably all three to their sentences
served in federal court rather than
state terry your reaction to the mother
wander cooper jones's comments to the
doj after a guilty verdict on all counts
as a mother brian i absolutely
understand her comments to the doj she
wanted him to know that this was not
enough she said basically that he was
thankful you know that he brought these
charges but she's not thankful that they
didn't pursue it and that they wanted to
do the plea deal so she had to go to
brunswick herself and she had to
basically convince the prosecutors to
not take that plea deal and she was very
upset about that what i will say is i do
think that merrick garland his press
conference i think he said he understood
and so i thought that that was good yeah
thankfully the judge rejected that plea
deal and we are here now with a guilty
verdict in florida the defense continues
its case in the trial of an ex-police
captain accused of murdering a man in a
movie theater curtis reeves is charged
with second-degree murder in the 2014
death of chad olson reeves said he shot
olson in self-defense after getting
frustrated when olson was on his cell
phone during movie previews defense
attorneys say olson threw his cell phone
at reeves and came toward him to attack
that's when they say reeves shot olson
in self-defense on tuesday the defense
called witnesses who testified that
reeves politely contacted movie theater
staff to report olson being on his cell
phone one eyewitness testified she saw
olson making a throwing motion towards
reeves while the defense argues that
motion was also throwing his cell phone
at an elderly reeves the prosecution
clarified what the motion was on
cross-examination
the motion that you saw was just a real
quick movement
towards the defendant not a throw
yeah it's just a quick motion okay so it
was not a throw not a throw and again
during this time that we're talking
about this quick movement that was not a
throw
you didn't think anything was happening
that you had to pay attention to correct
correct and that's why you went back to
watch the theater previews correct
and that quick motion you're talking
about
you didn't even think that was in a
threatening manner because you still
thought they were just friends
correct
also in florida the case of accused
serial killer robert hayes is now in the
hands of the jury hayes is being tried
for the murders of three women more than
15 years ago prosecutors say he shot and
killed laquita gunther julie green and
iwana payton officials say the three
women were sex workers in the daytona
beach area hayes was linked to the
killings after another woman was
murdered in 2016 in west palm beach
prosecutors say that victim rachel bay
was also a sex worker throughout its
case the prosecution focused on the dna
found on the first three victims the
defense says holes in the prosecution's
case didn't prove hayes was the one
responsible hayes defense team said in
closing arguments that the state didn't
prove hayes was even in town when the
women were killed just that he lived in
daytona beach if convicted in this case
hayes faces the death penalty he will
also be tried for rachel bay's murder in
west palm beach at a later date
still ahead on law and crime daily a
monumental settlement years in the
making what the united states soccer
federation agreed to pay five women's
soccer stars
but first murder or comfort care opening
statements are presented as an ex-doctor
stands trial for the murder of one of
one time patients
[Music]
hi this is dan abrams with exciting news
for all of our law and crime followers
on youtube you can now get the live lawn
crime network with youtube tv for all of
your daily live trial coverage legal
news expert analysis and original true
crime programs subscribe to youtube tv
today and then locate law and crime in
the channel guide and for only 1.99 a
month you can add the network to your
bundle
watch lawn crime every day with youtube
tv we put you in the jury box
[Music]
welcome back to law and crime daily the
trial is underway for an icu doctor in
ohio accused of murdering 14 patients by
giving them lethal doses of painkillers
and other drugs law and crimes angela
levy is here with what lawyers from both
sides told the jury and what a
pharmacist has to say
brian dr william husel was initially
charged with murdering 25 of his
patients but 11 of those counts of
murder were dismissed prior to the start
of the trial now prosecutors told the
jury that william hughsel is a murderer
who killed 14 patients and that the
doses he was prescribing for his
patients accelerated their deaths but he
says he was providing comfort care to
these terminally ill patients in the
mount carmel hospital in columbus ohio
the evidence will show that these drugs
were prescribed in massive doses in
combination with one another
during the ongoing covit 19 epidemic we
became aware of the use of ventilators
to care for people needing life support
being on a ventilator was not and is not
a death sentence
people do come off of them and live
unfortunately that was not the case for
the victims in this prosecution
and noted attorney jose baez who won an
acquittal for
casey anthony years and years ago in the
death of her daughter
he is representing dr heusel and told
him told the jury that he was providing
his patients with comfort care
there's no such thing as a medical
murder case
and that this is not a murder case
and it's far from it
william houston
was
exercising compassion
to his patients
and tried to free them from pain and let
their last moments on earth be ones of
peace
because that's
what his patients would have wanted
and that's exactly
what his patients family wanted
even when they begged him
to make sure that they were comfortable
and fentanyl is one of the drugs that dr
husel is accused of giving his patients
leading to their deaths and that is a
drug that we hear about a lot in the
news mostly because it's manufactured
illegally and placed into other drugs
and can be fatal i spoke with a
pharmacist though about medical grade
fentanyl and how that can be
administered in medical sentences or
settings rather and how much of it can
cause an overdose
every situation and every dose and every
patient is really different
fentanyl is really
one of the things we think about where
in in the world of pharmacy we kind of
have a phrase
that death can be by the decimal uh and
it's it's really an acknowledgement of
how the smallest differences in a dose
with high risk medications like fentanyl
can make a huge huge difference in terms
of what type of impact it's going to
have so whenever anyone who's a
pharmacist is seeing an order for
fentanyl they're going to be
scrutinizing it looking at it looking at
the dosage looking at the patient to
make sure that it's appropriate
now every patient is different
dr husel's trial is expected to last as
long as eight weeks and as many as 50
witnesses could testify
brian
thanks angela back to break down the
latest in the hugh cell pharmaceutical
murder trial is criminal defense
attorney bernardo violona and terry
austin terry we've learned from the
prosecution's opening that this wasn't
just about fentanyl allegedly being used
on these victims do you think that
changes anything for the defense
i don't think it changes a single thing
i think whether it's fentanyl or whether
it's a combination of drugs the real
issue is the fact that he over medicated
his patients and actually i think the
defense made some really great points he
basically said look this is a process
that involves not just doctors but
nurses and pharmacists so if one is
responsible they are all responsible and
he made it very clear that dr hossel
didn't go to med school to kill people
he spent 17 years getting educated and
he went to provide people with care near
the ends of their lives and so i think
that they have some valid points and one
other thing i'll say he's talked about
the fact that one of the patients he had
before he gave a similar amount and she
obviously uh needed that yeah i mean
bernardo people go to doctors to get a
second opinion all the time so my
question for you is after hearing the
defense is opening what are you
expecting from this case and do you
think that huso will take the stand
for his own defense
i think right now it's just too early to
see because i'm trying to get or gauge
through his opening statement is he
going with jury nullification or is he
going with that there is no intent in
terms of any of the charges that are
going to be put before them but if he's
going for jury nullification or for the
sympathy sympathy factor mr houston is
going to have to testify and give his
reasons why he acted in a way that he
did because the numbers are stacked
against him yeah it'd be interesting to
see how this plays out um with so many
different doctors and whatnot but
angenette has there ever been any talk
about a plea deal for dr husell
right before opening statements brian it
was really interesting there was
discussion about how there was this
possible plea deal in the works or an
informal discussion about one in which
dr hussell could plead to a reckless
homicide count or several reckless
homicide counts and possibly get out
with early release after a 30-year
sentence
but we're told
we're hearing in court this aft before
the opening statements that this was a
very informal conversation and jose baez
called it a starting point but there was
no deal to be had at least not today all
right i know these happen all the time
maybe it's a sign the prosecution
doesn't think their case is that strong
we don't know but of course we'll
continue to cover this case on the law
and crime network coming up on law and
crime daily opening statements are set
to be presented in the trial of former
louisville officer brett hankins
plus after a year's long bat legal
battle the united states soccer
federation dishes out a massive
settlement payment co-host terry austin
has the latest on the equal pay lawsuit
[Music]
welcome back after a years-long legal
battle a monumental settlement is
reached in an equal pay lawsuit spurred
by united states women's soccer players
as co-host terry austin explains terms
of the settlement could benefit women's
soccer players for years to come
brian on top of the 24 million dollars
the u.s soccer federation has agreed to
pay out terms of the settlement also
specify male and female soccer players
will receive equal pay from here on out
this landmark settlement stems from a
2016 complaint and later 2019 lawsuit
that cited ongoing gender discrimination
against female soccer players megan
rapino and alex morgan spearheaded the
effort citing a large wage gap between
male and female players and different
working conditions in a joint statement
the players and u.s soccer said in part
the u.s women's national team players
have achieved unprecedented success
while working to achieve equal pay for
themselves and future athletes terms of
the settlement mean u.s soccer will dish
out 22 million to five players who file
suit on top of that a separate two
million dollar account will be set aside
for other female players to use for
plans in a post-soccer playing career
brian
thank you terry for let's bring in
criminal defense attorney bernard
veolona for this landmark settlement in
the soccer world we're going to break
down this 24 million dollar settlement
where does the money go for now and the
future
so in regards to the settlement itself a
part of that settlement actually a bulk
of that settlement is essentially back
paid to those players that played under
those unequal paid situations so that's
going to go as back pay which goes to
show you that there is a significant
amount of guilt in terms of the
association in terms of what will happen
in the future i really hope that they
can stick by this agreement and that
there will be equal pay amongst men as
well as women's soccer players yeah and
also i would add in let's hope that this
changes the way that fifa dishes out uh
their bonuses for winning in the
tournament as well as ad space being
sold because that's really where a lot
of this comes into play terry this has
been a long fought battle for the
women's national team does this pave the
way for pay equity in other sports
absolutely this settlement pays the way
not just for women in other sports but
for women in all areas of life listen
it's already effectuated some change we
know that trinity rodman dennis rodman's
daughter just recently signed the
largest contract for women's soccer in
history so i think that megan repino and
alex morgan the lawyers everyone who was
involved in this lawsuit basically did
pave the way for younger people and in
fact we're hearing that this is justice
for the next generation yeah i can say
as a former college soccer player myself
i am happy to see this change and hope
to see more equity in the players both
men and women
when we come back the state of kentucky
versus brett hankinson just days before
openings a snag on the witness list why
a former officer now says he will plead
the fifth if called to the stand
[Music]
welcome back to law and crime daily just
days before the only officer charge in
connection to the death of brianna
taylor is set to stand trial a second
ex-officer announces he will plead the
fifth and not testify in the trial
opening statements for the trial of
brett hankinson are expected to be
presented on wednesday hankinson is not
charged in the death of brianna taylor
but instead faces charges of wanting
endangerment for firing shots into an
apartment near taylor's in march 2020
officers executed a no-knock warrant to
taylor's apartment her boyfriend
believing the officers were intruders
fired shots at them the prosecutor the
officers shot back and taylor was killed
in the crossfire ex-louisville officer
john mattenly who assisted hankinson in
the raid now says he will invoke his
fifth amendment right and not testify
court documents showing mattingly will
not testify on quote grounds his
testimony could incriminate him for
purposes of future proceedings mattley
was the only officer involved in the
incident not to be fired he instead
resigned opening statements in
hankinson's trial are set to begin on
wednesday law and crime network and i
will be inside the louisville courtroom
to bring you gabital gavel coverage
bernardo break down the charges for us
what exactly is wanton endangerment
pretty much in this case what happened
is that a wall got more justice than
brianna taylor in terms of what
hankinson is actually charged with
because remember no homicide charges
were presented to the grand jury for
their consideration to determine whether
there should be homicide charges in this
case so what he was charged with is
pretty much reckless endangerment and
the fact that he exercised an extreme
indifference to the individuals that
were inside of the other apartments on
the other side of the wall and because
he exercised an extreme indifference
they're charging him because he actually
fired into other doors or the walls that
weren't associated with beyonce taylor's
apartment
so terry i i think that as we're
watching this case in louisville play
out it's going to be interesting to see
as bernardo pointed out that there seems
to be charges for a wall or neighbors
but not brianna do you think this trial
will give us more questions or answers
as we explore this case why and what are
some of those questions
oh i definitely think people are going
to have more questions i think they
don't really understand the three counts
of wanting endangerment look against the
other apartment other people in that
apartment okay but people are thinking
to themselves but you also endangered
brianna taylor and why aren't you being
charged with endangering her because you
literally absolutely they all caused her
death listen hankinson fired 10 times
and several of those bullets did go into
the neighboring apartment cosgrove and
badly they also fired but they claimed
they were justified because they were
returning fire as far as kenneth walker
was concerned the boyfriend but i think
this trial is going to confuse people
because they do not understand and it's
hard to understand the prosecution's
rationale for not literally charging
hankinson and all of them frankly for
endangering the life of brianna taylor
because at the end of the day she
literally ended up dead all right we'll
see how this plays out as opening
statements are set for wednesday thank
you both and thank you for joining us
here on law and crime daily we'll see
you next time as we discuss justice in
america
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you